jeff you say making a movie is like
starting a new business
why make that comparison making an
independent movie
um there's so much to it i mean there's
so many components to making a movie
think of
you're creating something from scratch
from an idea so and that's what a
business is you have an idea
and you want to bring it to life and
bring whatever it is your product or
service to market
and you have to go through all those
steps and components in order to do that
i mean that's what making a movie is
ultimately you're going to develop it
produce it mar and then market it
and so that's what a business is it's
creating like a product or service
and then putting it out to market and
hoping that consumers
consume it and in case of a movie it's
that consumption is watching it
or buying it you know whatever in that
case um so
how is that any different than any
business that's what all businesses do
they create from an idea a product or
service and put it out to market to be
consumed
and that's why i relate it to a business
now in
in the studios there's two types of
i i believe that the studio business and
the independent business are actually
two separate businesses
the way a public company would be
different than
an entrepreneurial company so let's deal
with the public company so a public
company has shareholders
and they have a responsibility and a
mandate to earn
revenue for you know and dividends or
whatever for their shareholders
that's their mission their mission is to
create wealth so that they can
distribute it to their shareholders
so everybody's focused on that on wealth
creation and
you know and whatever it takes to be
profitable
that's why corporations exist especially
public corporations
in the case of a so that's what a studio
is
i mean every studio is a public company
so every studio
has to be financially successful for two
reasons one if they're not
they can't exist and make the products
they want to do and two is their
shareholders wouldn't support
it so the studios are public
companies and they are financial
institutions that create wealth
that's the way i look at them they
happen to be the product they happen to
be making is you know entertainment
movies tv shows whatever
but it's for the reason of generating
profit
there's not many studio people i've met
who will say to you
i want to do this because this is what i
like and enjoy and it doesn't matter if
we make profit
they won't last too long in the studio
system they have to be profit oriented
on the entrepreneurial side which is
what i would relate to the indie
filmmaking business
you also if you want to exist and
continue you
you do have to make a profit like any
business
but you can take more risks the stakes
are not lower and you're not
you're not accountable to anybody other
than yourself and your investors
on the public company side you're
accountable to all your shareholders
here the accountability factor is less
so
you don't want to blow your brains out
and lose all your investors money or
whoever it is it might just be your own
money in your own time
but you're you have the ability to take
more risks which is what an entrepreneur
does
um maybe have a little bit more fun
maybe go
a little bit more passion do the things
that you truly want to do
like when i speak to filmmakers um the
two questions they always ask me is
what genre film should i make that would
be most saleable
and that's question number and i answer
that question and i say
great question but let me ask you a
question before i answer your question
what genre film do you like to make see
in a studio you'd never have that
discussion
that would be we need to make here's
what's trending here's what's happening
in the marketplace here's what we're
forecasting
this is where we're going to make the
most amount of money in the entrance
nobody says hey
what do you think we should do what
would be the most fun what would be like
the most artistic
in the entrepreneurial world you can
have that conversation art actually
matters
i mean you know listen in the studio
world you have to make good product it
has to be
fantastic and very artistic in order for
people to be entertained by it
but they don't have the luxury of
picking and choosing the way an
entrepreneur does
because they're again they're
accountable to a smaller group of people
so but on the business side why related
to a business is because
when you decide to make a movie from
start to finish
if you want to be a what i call a career
filmmaker
who makes just more than one movie um
it would be helpful if you were
profitable because that way
one you'd have enough money you'd make
your money back which would help to make
your next movie
two that would evoke investor confidence
if you are
dealing with investors they would say
hey this guy's you know able to make
money
with the stuff we're investing in so so
it does make it a lot easier
if you're profitable on the
entrepreneurial side
but you don't have to necessarily be
profitable because i mean
it might not lead to a good career but
you could be what you know a hobby
filmmaker just an artist
who says i have a statement that i want
to make to the world and i'm going to do
it through a movie
and it's important for me this is this
is the kind of movie i want to make this
is
the artistic integrity that i i don't
really want to compromise so i'm not
really worried
about what the audience thinks i'm more
worried about what i think
i personally don't think that makes for
necessarily great business practice
because
it might not generate the profit that
you're looking for
but an entrepreneur gets to do that
that's part of being in business
and you know if you look at the
statistics of entrepreneurs
most small businesses fail miserably
um it's really really tough to navigate
opening a new business that would be the
same with indie films
the good news about making any film is
even though you didn't make any money
and you could say it sort of failed
financially
it didn't necessarily fail artistically
so you left you're going to leave the
world with your legacy
and your message and whatever and
hopefully audiences will enjoy it maybe
they didn't pay for it but hopefully
they'll enjoy it so at least you get
that out of it whereas a failed business
on the entrepreneurial side you know
unless they open a restaurant or
a clothing store or something like that
and fails i mean you're just left with a
lot of debt and a lot of aggravation
right that's that was actually i was
going to bring up the next thing is is
certain businesses of course
and i was wondering if we could make
that comparison to certain types of
movies so if you have
a restaurant which what is it 90 failure
rate i'm not sure if that that's the
right percentage
but then versus say someone selling
widgets
and it's it's led lights and it's all
the rage
are certain movies in the category of
the restaurant and certain
movies are in the category of the
widgets um i would look at it a little
differently
because you know certain restaurants in
certain locations i think have a better
chance than other restaurants in other
locations
so so i would say certain
there's a trend in the movie business
you know as you know like sometimes
horror movies are the hot rage
sometimes it's sci-fi um i
and there's you definitely if you're in
it to make money if you're in the film
business to make money
you definitely have to consider what
your audience wants to see and who your
audience actually is
and that was the second question like i
always said they say you know
what what film should i make and the
second question is actually how do i get
it to the audience
so the first way to get a film to an
audience is to identify who the audience
is
which means you have to choose the genre
of film that
you are going to aim at your audience so
for example i
tend to make family films i like family
films i enjoy making them i enjoy
the genre i for kids they were growing
up it was a
nice thing for me to do but i did it
because i really enjoy family films
so and then within family films i'm very
specific my films are very specific
they're generally sports dramas based on
true stories
because i love that genre and
it's very very marketable especially
each one
has a definition a defined market so
like i've made two gymnastics films
so i can go to the gymnastics world and
i'm able to actually target market
gymnasts and dancers so i don't have to
go generically across the whole gambit
to try to market to everybody
i can specifically hone my marketing
efforts in on you know gymnasts and
dancers who
i would think would be engaged by the
movie by these particular movies
which has worked so as a business
decision
it does help to to identify the audience
that you want to go to
and then you know choose the movie that
hopefully will cater to that audience
or vice versa if you're going to choose
a movie
make sure you identify how you're going
to who the audience is and how you're
going to market to them before you make
the movie
otherwise you it's hard to do it after
the fact
you gotta have i mean this is what
studios do i mean i'm convinced i've
never worked in a studio but i'm a
hundred percent convinced
that if the marketing department doesn't
green light the movie then the
production
department's not making it they need to
know who that's going to how it's going
to get marketed what the plan is going
to be
in order to monetize you know the
product they make and
indie film producers generally don't do
that but if they did do that then
it kind of like a restaurateur opening a
restaurant
like if you're going to open say an
indian restaurant
in an asian marketplace
it could be it could be tricky i don't
know maybe
asian people like indian food but you
better do your research and make sure
they do
otherwise your restaurant could be
fantastic it just might be in the wrong
place
and that's the same with the film like
you know if you're gonna
make a film that caters to a certain
audience and you haven't really
identified who the audience is or how to
get to them
you can make the greatest film of all
time but it's going to be hard to get at
your audience
you know and you had mentioned earlier
and i love this point that you're making
um
about clothing and it brings back uh
something i watched about diane von
furstenberg and her wrap dress
which was all the rage i think it was
late 70s 80s
and then i think she got in trouble
because she went and bought a new
inventory and it was so popular
but taste had changed if i remember
correctly so she had all this inventory
that was not selling at the time i think
it made a resurgence later
but do audiences that that's the thing
if
we know the rage is horror movies with a
certain
soundtrack and different things can the
audience change and now you've got this
this excess surplus i have a
maybe a bit of a skewed opinion about
that so
i believe that anything that is unique
good and really entertaining will can
actually create a trend itself
and can find an audience and
you know it's funny i notice over the
years especially with studio pictures
that's always with studio movies um
trends seem to develop like
you know you know in the 70s you had
this star wars star
trek all these star you know space
themes right
like that doesn't just come out of
nowhere so i've always thought about
like
how does a trend like that develop do
people
like audience members or whatever you
know consumers write into studios and
say hey
we want to see star movies like they
don't
here's how i think it develops i think
that that creative people
develop these stories and then they go
pitch them to studio execs
and um you know in the case of again i
just read about lucas and star wars so i
don't know for sure i've never met lucas
i've never interviewed him but
but it's you know he says in his book
that he went to everybody he knocked on
every single door many times and got
rejected with star wars
but every time because i worked in big
media companies but every time
a filmmaker walks out the door after
they've pitched a crazy unique concept
they leave and and the executives in the
room say
yeah it was crazy but but what if like
you know like at warner brothers they
say what if paramount
takes it and we're wrong like what about
this so you notice that like when one
movie comes out
five movies come out and i think it's
because nobody
wants to be wrong so they have to cover
themselves and make sure they have
something else to offer
um because while all of a sudden the
five star movies the star wars movies
are
related type of stuff come out why all
of a sudden is there a
a run on horror movies or run on
westerns
or romantic comedies or stuff like that
there's generally a run on them
and generally you know i mean the movie
business is driven by the studios and
the big movies the theatrical movies
and i think there's a run on them
because every studio doesn't want to be
wrong so they have to hedge their bets
to make sure that whoever
green lit whatever they did and they
didn't green light it they have
something to cover
that's my theory okay it's a conspiracy
theory that's what i believe to be true
because it's just too random that
everybody would be looking at the same
stuff at the same time
randomly so i feel like that's how it
happens
now there are genres that are evergreen
i personally think family is an
evergreen genre that's one of the
reasons i work in it
because as long as there's families as
long as there's kids that grow up and
want to their parents want to view
movies together there needs to be family
movies so i believe that's evergreen
most genres are evergreen just some are
trending
more than others but the way the way
that clothing trends
and cars trend and that type of thing i
believe it's all based on marketing and
i believe the studios
sort of decide what the audience is
going to see
and when they're going to see it it's
not the audiences who demand something
the studios say
we're going to now move it into this
genre we're going to release
10 horror films we're going to release
10 rom-coms or whatever
and that's what we're doing because
i'm not sure why that's what we're doing
and which makes a trend develop
or die it's a great point like found
footage
so blair witch and it seemed like it it
tipped off other found footage films and
it became all the rage after a while
it did but you know in order for a trend
to develop
it's not necessarily only part of it is
what people are making
it's primarily what is being released by
studios
so there could be you know 10 of those
kind of blair witch style movies
um the first one happened to be
successful so they might as well run a
few more and see how that goes
but if if the second and third are not
successful you can be sure that's going
to die very quickly as quickly as it
started
so the trends really go with the profit
like they put them out they see what
happens if it makes profit then they go
with more and more
until they exhaust it and then they have
to come with something else
it's kind of like fashion i think
you